the presidency of the EU council is a
big job now it falls to one of the
smallest member states lithuania less
than a year before european elections
with much unfinished business lithuania
faces a to-do list that his eighty-five
percent inherited from previous
presidencies and as the economic crisis
the country's president told MEP she
wants to restore EU credibility
credibility is essential for a stable
economy and this task force equally on
the presidency on the parliament their
Commission and all member states
president hrabowski eita said her
priorities are completing the internal
energy market which could save Europe 35
billion euros a year she said addressing
youth unemployment and developing better
relations with Eastern neighbors who
have been invited to a summit in Vilnius
in November very important to give a
clear signal to Ukraine and some of the
Eastern neighbors that they are
welcoming Europe and we don't want them
to be blackmailed by Russia for Miss
escribas kite it matters to connect the
democratic challenges with a better
offer from Europe for better development
in the Member States several members
raised concerns about homophobia in
Lithuania and a gay pride march banned
by Vilnius authorities at a press
conference President Grievous Gaeta said
it will go ahead it's a question of
where but she also stressed the
importance of an energy market in
tackling unemployment it's not only
about training is not only about new
models of vocational training it's also
about a general economic growth and
general competitiveness for Europe is
affordable energy resources affordable
prices her priorities met general
support Lithuania is the first Baltic
state to hold the presidency and as a
former commissioner President grabowski
tur knows her way around the EU
Lithuanian mebs have faith in the future
anyway we will not step back if union is
not stepping back the second presidency
in any year includes the summer leaving
less time to complete an ambitious
agenda but Lithuania is determined to
exceed expectations
you